je vous ai demandé des événements qui
vous ont marqué en tout cas qui ont été
marquants des événements météo pioneer
ça remonte comme métier métérologue pas
pour être du canada dans le west end
j'ai commencé dès maintenant 86 se
jetait métérologue opérationnel donc je
faisais les prévisions météo et moi je
travaillais au centre de prévision de
l'arctique donc on s'occupait des
prévisions pour le nord mais l'autre
côté du mur il y avait le centre de
prévisions de l'alberta c'était donc
maintenue et le 31 juillet 1987 il ya
cette fameuse tornade qui a dévasté une
partie de la ville alors 31 juillet 1987
27 mars après la tornade la deuxième
tornade la plus meurtrière de l'histoire
mais la première est à 28 morts en 1912
on qu'on voit c'est vraiment une
catastrophe historique va de 400 km à la
soif une tornade f4 c'est ce que ça
s'apparente de ce que vous voyez sur
l'oklahoma où d'autres existent quant au
mode et peut-être naître qui dévaste
tout c'est un kilomètre de largeur le
corps ou un kilomètre de largeur avoir
un peu plus et cette tornade suivi un
parcours sur 40 kilomètres ça a duré une
heure une heure de dévastation totale
alors j'étais là je vous l'avais vu je
l'aï vu c'est à peu près ça ce qu'on
vous montre ce sont des images qui ont
été captés
quand la tornade commencé à toucher
terre à l'extérieur de la ville elle se
rapprocha c'était en banlieue à se
rapprocher de la ville mais moi je l'aï
vu quand elle était tout près du chemin
alors ce sont dix matches ont été
captées à partir du bureau
météorologique et c'était ce que je
voyais du toit passer que la petite
histoire je vous raconte moi je
travaillerai pour la liberté mais pour
l'arctique alors quand un suc la tornade
se rapprochait du but rennais passe à
quelques cas quelques kilomètres du
bureau météo des collègues se sont dit
on va monter sur le toit pour l'avoir
parce que la grande majorité des
météorologues n'ont jamais vu de
tournage mais c'est vrai c'est vrai
c'était d'une rareté total ya un monstre
pareil on voulait la voir aller on est
montés sur le toit on voyait quelque
chose qui s'apparentait à ça et je me
rappelle très bien moi j'avais 25 ans
j'étais complètement c'est incroyable
gens croyaient pas que je pense que je
voyais et je me rappelle que je suis
resté plusieurs minutes mais quand je me
suis retourné mes collègues avaient
disparu mais avait laissé sur le toit
je suis donc descendu j'ai fermé la
trappe du toit je redescends d'uckange
servira de bureau météo le centre de
prévision des articles n'avaient plus
personne vous avez évacuer le bureau
carrément alors je me suis dirigé vers
le bureau de l'alberta et à ce moment là
ce que vous voyez il y avait un intérêt
logique ce qui est en train de filmer la
tornade ça ce sera à partir du bureau de
météo de l'alberta et elle est en train
de filmer je me rappelle j'étais tout
prêt de lui je le voyais faire et on m'a
dit tout de suite on évacue tout le
monde dans le sous sol dont le garage
souterrain de quelques personnes qui
sont restés là pour justement couvrir
les prévisions et continue de filmer ce
monstre qu'est ce que vous voyez ça
c'est le stationnement du bureau météo
l'internât se déplace à quelques
kilomètres seulement le débat sites et
les raffineries déverser des quartiers
résidentiels
il paiera mais fascinant pour un
météorologue complètement mais est prêt
mais c'était c'est terrorisant moyenne
soit c'est un immense à un kilomètre de
large est immense regarder les dégâts ça
a été la dévastation totale et je me
rappelle très bien
d'avoir vu parce que ça a ravagé une
partie des raffineries des quartiers
industriels avoir une citerne renversée
à l'envers complètement compte tenu de
la force de se tourner d'entraînement
puissante auxerre va complètement
marquer évidemment j'avais 25 ans je
commençais ma carrière